[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à l'entretien de
france 24 et avec monsieur rached el
ghanouchi président du parti à nanterre
et président du parlement tunisien
dissous bienvenue monsieur al ghanouchi
et merci d'avoir répondu favorablement à
cette invitation qu'en est il des
accusations vous visant de blanchiment
d'argent et que vous aviez utilisé le
mot altar haute aux tyrans pour
qualifier les forces de l'ordre bonjour
à vous et à tous les téléspectateurs
ce qui s'est produit hier c'est que j'ai
été invité à une audition
pour qu'on me pose des questions
concernant un prêche lors de d'une
oraison funèbre
d'un activiste de notre parti où j'ai
prononcé le mot ta route tirant qui a
été considéré comme une insulte contre
les forces de l'ordre mais j'ai clarifié
aux enquêteurs et j'ai dit qu'il n'en
était rien et que en réalité c'était
l'éloge funèbre
pour
feu monsieur phal 30 aubade où j'ai dit
que il était courageux qu'il n'avait pas
peur des tirs il n'avait peur de rien
et donc je parlais
de la période avant la révolution avant
la révolution le régime n'était pas
démocratique c'était une dictature
la régime despotique et donc le mot tir
en parler de ce régime là despotique et
dictatorial
j'ai eu accès à cet enregistrement
monsieur andré nouschi
et même si vous n'avez pas dit
explicitement les forces de l'ordre
certains considèrent que l'utilisation
de ce terme est une incitation contre
les forces de l'ordre et que cela
reflète votre réelle idéologie
l'idéologie du parti et de ses leaders
est ce que cela est vrai que ça n'est
pas la vérité c'est une manipulation de
la vérité le parti ennahda est l'un des
piliers de la lutte contre l'extrémisme
contre le terrorisme
le parti ennhada
sa référence c'est l'islam et c'est pour
cela que nous sommes capables à répandre
à tous les arguments des extrémistes
quand ils prétendent de manière fausse
qu'ils sont musulmans qu'ils disent que
leurs actes sans islamique donc nous
avons les arguments théologiques pour
détruire leurs fondements théologiques
quand ils justifient leurs crimes leurs
actes terroristes et pendant ces
dernières vingt années nous avons
détruit le discours théologique des
terroristes non disons que leurs actions
n'ont rien à voir avec l'islam michael
sont contre l'islam qu'ils se trompent
dans leurs interprétations de l'islam qu
en est-il les accusations contre vous de
blanchiment d'argent
des accusations fausses rien n'a été
prouvé et c'est pour cela qu'on ne peut
pas parler de cela ce sont des
manipulations politiques certains
acteurs politiques
ennemis d'un canada ces acteurs
politiques qui ont échoué face à laon
nous lors des élections invente des
justifications des scénarios des
accusations de terrorisme le blanchiment
d'argent car ils ont perdu
lors des élections et sur l'arène
politique face à nous et donc c'est un
procès politique et c'est un procès
médiatique et votre chaîne ne doit pas
participer à ce procès ça n'est pas
impossible monsieur ghannouchi je veux
simplement clarifier mon cette
impression
hinault téléspectateurs sont tunisiens
mais pas qu'eux ils sont de tout le
monde arabe également et il faudrait
clarifier l'image la situation pour eux
notamment face à ce qu'a dit le comité
de défense de chokri belaid et de
mohamed gharbi
là vous venez de nommer monsieur
ghannouchi cet acteur politique
l'acteur politique dont je parle et qui
nous portent ces accusations ce n'est
pas la justice tunisienne c'est un
adversaire politique
donc maintenant cette affaire et devant
la justice et il faut attendre que la
justice tranche avant de parler de tout
cela et nous avons confiance dans la
justice tunisienne nous parlons toujours
et l'accusé présumé innocent jusqu'à
preuve du contraire donc on ne peut pas
évidemment en parler de cette affaire il
faut évidemment décennal de l'oci 6
évidemment nous ne portons aucune
accusation contre vous je veux
simplement avoir votre réponse votre
position concernant ce qu'a dit le
comité de défense de chokri belaid et de
mohammad gholami les accusations
d'assassinats politiques menées par
l'appareil secret de aïn berda quels
sont vos réponses face à ces accusations
ma réponse est simple
ces affaires sont maintenant devant la
justice il faut laisser la justice faire
son travail dire son dernier mot et
nous sommes sûrs que nous nous n'avons
aucun lien avec le terrorisme que tout
cela c'est une manipulation
politique et c'est un procès médiatique
c'est mon devoir de vous donner la
parole pour que vous donniez votre point
de vue sur ces accusations
vous dites que ses accusations ses
enquêtes contre vous actuellement
qu'elles sont des manipulations
politiques quelles sont vos preuves
ont continué le président crise a répété
ses accusations
vous continuez à répéter ces accusations
n'ont absoluement pourquoi pourquoi vous
continuer à porter ses accusations
messieurs rached ghannouchi je veux vous
donner la parole pour que vous donniez
votre point de vue donnez-nous vos
preuves
surtout que le président dit que la
justice est indépendante
je ne suis pas un défendons ici
vous voulez me mettre dans le box des
accusés non non absolument que je me
défende non
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
non absolument pas nous avait pas parlé
des politiques d'un mandat
vous voulez que je me défende et que je
prouve que je ne suis pas un terroriste
non ma question est la suivante vous
parler de manipulation politique c'est
de ça dont il s'agit vous dites que
c'est en 4 contre vous sont une
manipulation politique quel est votre
preuve
c'est d'accord allez-y à vous la parole
question suivante s'il vous plaît
d'accord question suivante alors le
président sayed dit que les actions
qu'il a entreprises sont nécessaires
pour sauver la tunisie que sa
constitution est une demande du peuple
pour rectifier la révolution les
partisans du président dise que la
participation au référendum n'est pas
faible que le peuple tunisien a dit son
monde il s'interroge pourquoi vous vous
opposez à la volonté du peuple
ce référendum était un échec ce
référendum
vise à légitimer le coup d'état du 25
juillet 2021 qui a dissous le parlement
le gouvernement la constitution
les instances de contrôle
et à travers le décret sont 17 qui est
la loi du président sayyed est devenue
la loi du pays cette loi est considéré
au dessus de toutes les lois de la
constitution les conventions
internationales les lois tunisiennes
donc ce référendum veut légitimer ce
coup d'état la démocratie tunisienne a
connu un vrai coup d'état un putsch une
tentative d'assassinât
comment peut-on considérer qu'une
constitution est valable alors que seuls
25% des électeurs ont participé
75 % des électeurs des tunisiens ont
boycotté ce référendum donc comment
peut-on légitimer une constitution avec
un taux aussi faible de participation
d'accor beaucoup vous accuser d'être
responsables de des agissements du
président sa manière d'exercer le
pouvoir de manière solitaire et
exclusive à cause de ce que vous avez
fait pendant la dernière décennie ap les
décennies de destruction ou vous avez
privilégié les intérêts personnels
quelle est votre réponse à cela la
dernière décennie nous étions pas seul
au pouvoir pendant la moitié de cette
décennie
c'était le party and ida qui était au
pouvoir il avait pris l'été à la tête de
toutes les instances de l'état nous
avons mené le gouvernement pendant deux
ans et après pendant cette décennie nous
avons participé de manière faible au
gouvernement la dernière décennie
n'était pas une décennie noire une
décennie de destruction s'était dessinée
de construction de la démocratie nous
avons
construit une grande constitution de
grandes institutions constitutionnelles
démocratiques notamment d'assemblée
nationale constituante des instances de
contrôle
et nous avons fait partie de la grande
famille des démocraties au niveau
mondial et c'est pour cela que la
communauté internationale a salué la
démocratie tunisienne à travers d'un
grand prix nous sommes devenu une icône
de la démocratie
dont le monde arabe et c'est pour cela
que les ennemis de la liberté les
dictatures complotent contre nous bien
sûr il a eu il ya eu des erreurs lors de
cette dernière décennie mais maintenant
les tunisiens regrette cette dernière
d'ici car actuellement ils n'ont pas
accès aux produits de base notamment
l'huile par exemple ces produits qui ne
sont pas à disposition sur le marché
alors que pendant la dernière décennie
tout était présent sur les marchés
tunisien et aucun blogueur n'a été
emprisonnés aucun député n'a été
poursuivi par un tribunal militaire
j'espère que vous allez répondre à cette
question monsieur ghannouchi vous parlez
d'une décennie de construction de
démocratie mais concernant le bilan de
votre parti pendant cette décennie les
critiques disent que vous avez ouvert
une faille qui a permis à beaucoup de
rentrer de gangréner l'état tunisien
notamment la justice il vise également
que vous avez laisser faire laisser
partir beaucoup de tunisiens sur les
champs de combat et de bataille quelle
est votre réponse face à ces accusations
en tout cas actuellement la vérité voit
le jour devant tout le monde le peuple
tunisien
souffre beaucoup plus du coup d'état au
niveau de sa vie quotidienne de ces
droits est maintenant le peuple tunisien
c'est que cette décennie n'était pas
noir
est ce que le parti ennahdha est ce que
vous avez peur que ce parti soit dissous
il ne sera pas dissout vous savez dans
le cadre d'une dictature tout est
possible
les dictatures
monsieur
kaïs saïd
dans sa conception du pouvoir
ne vois pas de place pour les partis les
syndicats les associations de la société
civile
[Musique]
sa vision du pouvoir c'est un seul homme
une seule opinion
et bien sûr dans ce cadre là tout est
possible votre parti est un des
principaux partis du pays vous avez
refusé de participer au référendum est
ce que vous allez participer aux
prochaines élections législatives
s'il y a des élections prochainement
nous allons d'abord étudié la loi
électorale et on va voir si monsieur
kaïs saïd veut
seul écrire la loi électorale
rédiger les règles du jeu
donc nous allons d'abord voir quelle est
la loi électorale
et à la lumière de cela nous allons
donner notre position
merci pour votre patience monsieur el
ghannouchi président du parti à noorda
et président du parlement tunisien
dissous merci chers téléspectateurs est
resté sur un câble
[Musique]